The Joe Rogan experience.
You know,
I heard a really great,
I,
this is just the beginning of a thought,
right?
Um,
but,
um,
it came up,
so just somewhere I was talking to,
um,
uh,
some people about this,
and in sports,
one of the things,
our assumption that men have an advantage over women,
right?
In sports,
in sports.
Yeah.
Our assumption.
Well,
yeah,
let me,
let me expand on our assumption that men have an advantage over women in sports,
um,
is partially based on the fact that so many of the sports were designed for male
bodies,
right?
They're optimized for male bodies,
Basketball for example.
Right.
Um,
uh,
you know,
there's an optimized for mail bombs.
It's like the,
uh,
the,
the height of the basket,
you know,
the,
um,
uh,
the way that the ball moves around,
you know,
like,
like even when the ball moves around,
if we're going to say that,
if,
if we're going to say that men and women have physiological differences,
right.
Um,
and then we're creating sports and the s and the sports are sort of tuned to the
physiological differences.
Okay.
[inaudible] we're talking about power,
speed,
athleticism,
all those,
there's an advantage when you look awesome
when you look at say gymnastics,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
I would say that like women for the events that are in a women's gymnastic
competition,
right.
Have an advantage over men,
right?
Um,
women,
uh,
women don't compete on the ring hold thing.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Uh,
men don't compete at,
at some of that crazy,
uh,
you know,
bar shit.
You know what I mean?
Like larger there its height,
its flexibility.
It's like there's a lot going on,
right?
So that's a rare case where women's gymnastics,
we've actually created events in that and like competitions that like only women
can do.
Right?
Um,
and so we sort of optimized that sport more for a female body.
Right?
What if we did that with a lot more sports?
Um,
and how about this?
What if we were able to do,
because again,
the rules of the game,
right?
Are not absolute.
The rules of the game are things that humans create,
right?
And so why do we s like maybe part of our assumption that men are better at
sports than women or men have an advantage on sports and women are that we have
constructed,
most of the Games that we've constructed are actually sort of biased towards a
male type of body.
Right.
That sounds ridiculous.
First of all,
he's and why gymnastics is like why women are good at gymnastics.
their,
their flexibility,
their lightness,
all those things.
Also,
they're not competing against men in a one on one type of situation.
Like one's trying to defend the other one's trying to tack like a game of
basketball or a game of football or any other sort of team sport with any male
gymnast and try to have them compete against the female.
That's not going to be a little,
those things.
It's a physical event as opposed to a sport.
So a physical event is you have to do this thing.
It's very athletic.
It's an athletic endeavor.
Should do as your balance.
You land.
No one's trying to stop you from doing it again.
When you're shooting basketballs,
you're not just shooting basketballs.
You're trying to shoot a basketball,
what people are trying to defend.
You're trying to Juke left and then go right.
You're trying to be sneaky.
You're trying to shoot from the outside.
There's all this shit going on in.
A lot of,
it involves your ability to move fast,
to close distance,
to have the physical strength of leap up in the air and there's a huge physical
advantage that men enjoy.
This is not because the sports designed this way,
it's because the sport is very simple.
There's a basket on one side of basket on the other side.
You got to get it in here.
They got to get it in there ready,
go.
If you're faster and your stronger,
you'll be able to accomplish that better.
Males are faster and stronger.
There's a reason why there's a male and a female division.
It's not that these sports were designed for males is that men are physically
bigger and stronger and faster than this.
These are physiological advantages.
Yeah.
You can have a thing like a gymnastics balance beam event where women are going
to shine because they're lighter and more flexible and they could do things with
their body that men can't because of the shape of their,
all the mass,
all the different things.
But that's rare.
That's the outlier.
I,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't think we actually disagree that much.
Um,
the reason it's rare is because historically we've created most of our sports
around things that men have the advantage,
and you're,
you're not wrong,
but sports are,
most sports involves speed and power.
Most sports.
But why men have an advantage in speed and power.
I know,
but we created those sports,
right?
Like what would we possibly be able to create where women would have an
advantage that is an athletic event where a man speed and power does not give
him an advantage.
I mean,
look,
man,
I this,
this is not,
uh,
again,
like I said,
this is the beginning of a thought,
right?
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to use this as a thought experiment is sort of like a,
a possibility opening device.
Right?
Right.
But so you,
you postulate,
hey,
now you make a fair point that there's a difference between individual athletic
events like gymnastics and competitive one on one or events like,
you know,
grappling or,
or basketball or something like that.
Right.
And so,
um,
and again,
I'm thinking this through myself as I'm talking about it,
right?
But,
um,
like I don't think it's impossible that you could come up with a one on one
competition that,
uh,
privileges that that is,
that is designed around the same athletic qualities that make a women make a
woman,
uh,
give her an advantage in a certain gymnastics event.
I don't think there's any reason you couldn't do the same thing for a find a one
on one competition that did the same thing.
Right.
Um,
there's also,
uh,
what could it be?
Uh,
I mean,
well,
here's an example.
Uh,
for instance,
uh,
I believe,
I'm not sure,
I'm not 100% sure,
but I believe in like shooting events,
right?
Uh,
for example,
that women and men are on a level playing field.
Correct.
Or,
or that,
uh,
like,
you know,
sort of air rifle sorta thing.
Um,
that like there are events,
right?
Uh,
there,
there do exist athletic events where you can have men and women in direct
competition with each other.
Right?
Where that,
where that event is not designed around a particular facet of a,
you know,
male or female body.
Right.
Um,
so,
uh,
my point is look,
men,
have you,
do you agree that men have run the country in the world for like most of
civilization?
Like,
and most every country.
Okay,
great.
So [inaudible] had been the one setting up the sports.
So the fact that as you say,
it's rare that we have sports that are sort of more designed around a female,
you know,
the differences between between women as opposed to men.
Right.
I think that might be because men had been setting up all the sports.
And so my,
so my point is sports that women gravitate towards.
How do you mean there's sports that women gravitate towards that you really
enjoy?
This mean like women's volleyball.
She ain't right.
Oh No,
this is,
there's many successful women have traditionally gravitated towards gymnastics
as you said earlier,
is puffy example.
But those are but way more women involved in gymnastics and men.
Oh,
absolutely.
Um,
but there,
those are the sports that get the less attention.
Right now we have less huge amounts.
It sure does.
It's one of the rare examples of like ones where,
you know,
that is a real female forward,
female first support.
Right.
No one bothers me the most is to volleyball.
Was that because the girls have to dress like hoes,
like even in the Olympics they wear thongs.
Jeanette fucking basketball players in the dress like that.
Yeah,
that's fucked up man.
They can choose what they're wearing.
I think that,
what's her name,
the Muslim Egyptian team,
they dress in national guards.
The name of the volleyball player who has,
has the black tape on,
um,
very famous.
You know,
the,
the two,
the two women,
the two women from the u s they're very famous volleyball players.
Whose names I can't remember.
They probably aren't complaining about what they're wearing.
They're probably choosing what they're wearing.
I don't know.
Um,
I don't think it,
let's forced them to wear that stuff.
But I mean,
when I tune into a Olympic volleyball,
my Tim Lee,
these girls in their underwear pretending they're at the beach,
they're not even at the beach.
It's a choice apparently towards they want to where they want to wear it.
I see.
I mean,
good move,
but is that a choice for the men?
Basketball players?
Can they wear thongs?
They can wear short shorts if they imagined where they could wear it,
like a cutoff with a midriff showing and a and little booty shorts,
they might be allowed to,
if they wanted to come back to see me,
I been narrow masculinity.
They might get shit in the locker room,
you know?
Maybe not.
Maybe they just make a point.
I like the short shorts that they used to wear a couple of decades ago,
so,
okay,
look,
yeah,
Larry Bird style.
You know,
one of the things I love about baseball and I started watching baseball is a,
you get to choose your own baseball pants.
He ever noticed that,
like they get to choose when you look at them.
Some of them were really tight baseball pants and then someone wear really baggy
baseball pants.
And I just love the managing.
I like clothes.
I imagine them going to like the baseball Taylor and being like,
dude,
I want to like sag my pants.
I want to,
you know,
show a little swag.
But you don't want to impede your performance.
So I think the tight would be better as you're running like good swimmer shaped
their bodies to be more aerodynamic.
I mean how much really if you're just running to first base,
how much does like baggy pants,
the wind catching the baggy pants cause that for real,
we look at like Manny Ramirez had like the baggy pants.
I remember.
And like you had to imagine that guy was like a little bit suboptimal with his
baseball pants.
You know,
maybe just call them up and stuff.
Yeah.
Maybe a big ass thighs and the only feel good with the baggy pants.
Let me just put a bow on,
on what I was trying to get earlier.
Right.
Cause I know I was,
I was sort of like getting to a pretty spacey place.
Um,
my point is just what our show is about so much is about showing how the things
that we take for granted in our world,
like the way the world is.
So much of the time is just something that we built.
Right?
And we can question it.
And so when we say men are men have advantages in women over sports,
I'm like,
well,
hold on a second.
Let's look at how we set the sports up and is it possible that we could set up,
set it up in a different way,
right?
That would allow more people to compete in sports.
Right?
It might not be the same sports.
I'm not going to say that women should play in the NFL against men.
Right?
I don't think that'd be safe.
I don't think anyone should play in the NFL.
Frankly.
I think it's way too dangerous.
Uh,
it's very bad for people.
But um,
uh,
is it like,
is our assumption just based on,
Hey,
these are the sports that we invented.
We happened to invent sports that were men have the advantage.
Can we imagine a world where 90% of sports are ones where women have an
advantage of would we be having a different conversation?
And if that's the case,
could we come up with some sports that,
like everybody could,
you know that where there's no,
uh,
this is,
it would have to say
physical sports I think.
Um,
but I think,
yeah,
you could come out with competitions were women and female.
Traditional female characteristics would have an advantage for sure.
You could,
I mean,
it could definitely be done,
you know,
it's just the ones that exist now when that involve running and lifting things
and moving fast,
physically,
physiologically males have an advantage.
Yeah.
That's why we have these distinctions and what's,
while we have men's divisions,
women's divisions over hundreds and hundreds of years ago,
you know what,
this just not fair.
It's not fair,
you know?
But you know,
I mean,
is it the like that's the,
that's the notion of fairness we have now.
I think the interesting thing about the question trans athletes is it's going to
challenge that notion.
It's going to lead to conversations like this one.
You know,
I think that's really cool.
And that's what I think we're sort of,
we should be down to have as a society.
Right.
Oh,
okay.